have the fortitude to do the right thing
not the easy thing
don't be somebody's lap dog or sick of
fans I think I spend probably fifty or
sixty percent of my time learning
reading talking to people traveling go
to work a place we respect the people
you think the company has the kind of
culture you like is going to grow is to
be ambitious do you want to be a winner
they compare yourself to the best and
acknowledged that will never happen
without hard work if you're not prepared
for tough times you're not gonna be you
can't like get prepared when times get
tough if I do well here I can help our
employees I help our clients of our
communities never fool yourself the
thinking that your success is yours
alone he's an American business
executive
he's a chairman president and CEO of
JPMorgan Chase he has an estimated net
worth of 1.1 billion dollars
he's Jamie Dimon and here's my take on
his top ten rules for success it takes
courage to be accountable throughout my
life throughout this crisis of the past
four years I have seen many people
embarrass themselves by failing to stand
up Billy mealy-mouthed and acting like
lemons by simply going along with the
pack I also saw plenty of people under
enormous pressure who always did the
right thing graduates you will soon
leave this wonderful community and
venture into a new world to get ready
for new jobs new opportunities and new
lives along the way you're going to face
a lot of pressure pressure to go along
to get along to toe the line to look the
other way when you see things that
aren't right and pressure deuce things
simply because everybody else is doing
them never give in to that pressure have
the fortitude to do the right thing not
the easy thing don't be somebody's lap
dog or sick of fans have the courage to
speak the truth even when it is
unpopular and have the courage to put
yourself on the line to strive for
something meaningful and even to risk
would be an embarrassing failure
I think Teddy Roosevelt understood this
to be a century ago when he said and I
quote is not the critic who counts not
the man who points out how the strong
man stumbles or where the doer deeds
could have done them better the credit
belongs to the man now the woman who is
actually in the arena whose face is
marred by dust and sweat and blood who
strives valiantly who airs who comes up
short again and again because there is
no effort without airing and shortcoming
but it does actually strive to do the
deeds who knows great enthusiasms the
great devotions who spends himself in a
worthy cause Who at the best knows in
the end of the triumph of high
achievement and who at the worst if he
fails at least fails while daring
greatly so that his place shall never be
with those cold and timid souls who know
neither victory nor defeat
learning is a lifelong thing it doesn't
end at Harvard Business School it's your
responsibility I think if you're in any
profession at all you have to do it
consistently all the time I think I
spend probably 50 or 60% of my time
learning reading talking to people
traveling it's the only way to keep on
top of this global world of ours and
it's even tougher now because of the
globality of the businesses you're all
going to deal in how reading is the most
important one but the second one which
is often forgotten is talking to other
people you can learn more from speaking
to people in 15 minutes then if you
spend your life doing something they can
explain it to you and you can learn from
watching people you also are going to
learn by I'm going to call it imitation
but by watching other very good people
and how they operate in difficult
circumstances I learned a lot of things
what not to do analyze what to do by
watching other people go to work a place
we respect the people you think the
company has the kind of culture you like
is going to grow as to be ambitious and
your career will take who knows what
path and you know do think I had a
couple of jobs so that you're always
thinking maybe what I might want to do
next and you know one point life you
have to make a vertical switch or some
point life may get fired like some of us
have been in a war and those those are
hard things but they could be very good
things so some I've also find some
people said that's what they want and
they're looking up those hundred stairs
and always measuring how quickly the
going versus their friend that's it you
know you're not doing the right thing
unjoin your job your your you know it
takes a lot of luck to get to that top
rung sometimes and and if you're really
good you probably get there it may not
be at that company they may be somewhere
else so I tell you enjoy your life enjoy
every step of it and don't don't worry
too much about that kind of ambition
many of you already have dealt with some
very difficult times so this is no
different than some of you already dealt
with when you fail it's okay to get
depressed it's okay to cry it's okay to
go home it's okay
to blame others for a while but
eventually you have to get over it and
move on the greatest people have ever
walked this planet and if I'm talking
I'm not talking business people I'm
talking about people like Nelson Mandela
and Abe Lincoln constantly had setbacks
in life and failures constantly
all the time in business and some of
your success will be how you deal with
the failure not how you deal with the
success when I get introduced I always
get introduced that 1998 I was the
president of Citigroup and in 2000 I
took over Bank 1 I was fired in 1998 so
I went a little bit of experience like
this and and it's a painful thing my
boss had worked for 15 years called me
in and said we want you to resign which
I said ok I went home I told my wife and
children I called my wife up and said
Judy I'm going to tell you something I'm
not kidding because I always make jokes
about things like that
but I wanted to make sure the kids were
fine I went home my three wonderful
daughters they were much younger than I
said the oldest youngest one said dad do
we have to sleep on the streets
I said no hon we're okay the middle one
who just graduated Barnard said dad can
I still go to college
I suggest you you can and I knew things
were fine when the oldest one was going
to Harvard Business School said dad I
have that little cell phone you have you
won't be needing it
and I remind people when you fail at
something it's your I told you about
Citigroup is my net worth not my
self-worth and I was able to move on and
yes it was difficult I did call my boss
a year later he did not call me I called
him and said it's time to break bread we
went to lunch together I told them that
entity did the right thing for Citigroup
which is pretty obvious at this point
but but I told him the mistakes I made
and was 40 60 or 60 40 wasn't important
I wanted to learn from the experience
and move on if you want to be a winner
then compare yourself to the best and
acknowledge that will never happen
without hard work Abe Lincoln used to
say good things may come to those who
wait but only those things left by those
who hustle if you want to be a leader
act like a leader if you want to be
respected and trusted then demonstrate
you deserve it by earning it every day
if you want to be known as honest not
telling lies is not sufficient don't
even shave the truth and make sure your
friends and colleagues will always bring
you back to earth when you like we all
do at times for deceiving yourself you
know you all your management is I think
it's kind of relentless process so I
guess first like someone said we would
have what happened with changing the
crisis versus before nothing it's like
if you're not prepared for tough times
you're not going to be you can't like
get prepared when times get tough like
you need the army before the war starts
and so that means a discipline group
they know what they're doing the only
real difference is that the or risk
committee used to meet once a week for a
couple hours and in the crisis of met at
7:00 a.m. 12:00 lunch time five o'clock
10 o'clock 5:00 a.m. that they had to
24/7 for six to eight months and we had
to say it wasn't very formal we said hey
if you've got a problem go to the mean
and bring the people you got to have and
everyone shares the reports that shares
the information tries to react very
quickly there is already a book on you
that book is already being written and
if I spoke to your teachers your friends
your professionals your parents I would
know whether you're trusted how
you work with your ethical I would know
so much about you you'd be shocked I
don't even have to meet you so that book
is already growing you should you write
the book you want the way to be written
you actually have that choice and you
can do it as you want now don't let
others write it and when you get caught
in situations that you're uncomfortable
I remember I worked at a company not far
from here and I remember I was asked to
do something I didn't want to do I might
tell you I'll take this advice you can
always quit it's your responsibility
whether you accept to do something not
and it will be in that book written on
you you had a major life-changing event
how are you doing I'm doing fine thank
you so far so good I get tested all the
time how has it changed you at all how
does it impacted you it didn't change my
value system which I've always literally
family first country and humanity second
because I go hand in hand to me but I
think this country still is the leading
beacon in the world if you actually
travel around the world you feel that
way too and you know third is the job
but this is the best I can do you know
so if I do well here I can help our
employees I help our clients all of our
communities and the only real change is
that which I think it's just a good life
lesson is that I don't necessary my my
live for 10 years and you want to live
very deliberately like why are you doing
this the cities because you want to end
every day and say that was a good day I
but I always tell people it is it is
your job to take care of your if you
have a job you know and we all spend a
lot of time there but your job to take
you of your mind
your spirit your body your soul and your
family and you've got to take that
officially so I do I've always taken my
vacations I've always had my family
trips I always you know cut something
short for the family this phone 24/7 is
used for emergencies and children and my
wife that's it
it takes humility and humanity to be
accountable we all stand on the
shoulders of those who came before us
humility is the realization that those
who came before pave the way never fool
yourself the thinking that your success
is yours alone
your success is the result of your
parents the family was sacrificed to
give you a better life your professors
and administrators who helped you get
through your time your Syracuse your
friends neighbors those who encouraged
you in fact this wonderful country whose
bounties we all benefit from was built
by so many people who made endless
sacrifices often the ultimate sacrifice
before most of us were even born there's
important to respect what they have done
and to be grateful for it
thank you guys so much for watching we
made this video because female foot kids
there asked us to if there's someone
else you'd like us a profile leave a
message in the comments below we'd also
love to know which of the top ten rules
hit you the hardest and why leave in the
comments and we'll join in the
discussion thank you so much for
watching
continue to believe and we'll see you
soon